ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Increased
regulatory and compliance
requirements mean that
protecting sensitive data
is top-of-mind for
many organizations.
Data Catalog's integration with
Cloud Data Loss Prevention,
DLP, make it easy to quickly
discover PII information
and catalog it accordingly.
Up next, we'll dive into how
Data Catalog helps you manage
your sensitive data sets.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Data Catalog is a fully managed
and scalable data discovery
and metadata management service
that empowers organizations
to quickly discover,
understand, and manage
all their data in Google Cloud.
I am Anita Kibunguchy,
and today, we'll
be tackling how to manage your
data assets with automatic PII
scanning capabilities
using the DLP
integration in Data Catalog.
Knowing what's in your
data is the first step
to understanding
how to govern it.
Traditionally, finding,
tagging, and handling PII
is an extremely manual and
time-consuming process.
Cloud DLP integration in
Data Catalog scans your data
and automatically discovers
what's sensitive about it.
The data is then
tagged and the metadata
pushed into Data Catalog.
So you can easily search
and govern it accordingly.
Not only will Cloud
DLP inform you
if there's any PII
in your data sets,
but it will tell you
what kind of PII.
Cloud DLP has over 90
types of sensitive data
identifiers, including social
security numbers, passport
numbers, birth dates, and more.
Cloud DLP integration
is currently
available via API
only, but will soon
be available within
the Data Catalog UI.
As a result, you can process
large amounts of data
quickly and automatically,
simplifying the process
of governing sensitive data.
Thanks for watching.
And please check out all our
Data Catalog videos, or visit
our website to learn more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]